[Music]
uh you know a couple weeks ago around
Palm Sunday you you talked and this was
a such a enlightening talk about uh when
Jesus is coming into Jerusalem and the
people are singing hosana um and you
talked about that but I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit about uh the
Luke account particularly when he says
and you've probably done this before but
sorry if I've missed it but when when he
says that these uh if they were to cease
when the Pharisees say rebuke them that
these Stones would cry out can you um
tell me a little about the significance
of that well that's that's what we call
hyperbole that even inanimate objects
recognize the Creator when he shows
up you understand meaning if you human
beings refuse to worship me even stones
have enough sense more sense than you
though they're inanimate to know who I
am and give me
worship amen I'll give you a parallel to
that I hope you guys understood his
question what did Jesus mean when he
said if they didn't praise me even the
stones would cry out what does he mean
is that humans who are supposed to be
sensible at times are stupider than
rocks why because even inanimate
creation meaning rocks and trees that we
don't attribute Consciousness to realize
the Creator when he shows up and they
realize Jesus is the creator let me give
you a parallel to this you ready yes go
to Mark 4:
35-41 Mark
43541 I hope you understood his question
and my answer because these are
excellent questions and I pray the Holy
Spirit is giving us answers that are
deep Mark 4:34 no Mark 4:35 to 41 35- 41
okay and the same day when the even was
come he saith unto them let us pass over
unto the other side and when they had
sent away the multitude they took him
even as he was in the ship and there
were also with him other little ships
and there arose a great storm of wind
and the waves beat into the ship so that
it was now full and he was in the hinder
part of the ship asleep on a pillow and
they awake him and say unto him Master
carest thou not that we perish and he
arose and rebuked the wind and said unto
the sea peace be still and the wind
ceased and there was a great calm and he
said unto them why are ye so fearful how
is it that ye have no faith and they
feared exceedingly and said one to
another what manner of man is this that
even the wind and the Sea obey him now
notice the wind and the Sea recognize
the voice of their Creator God they
recognized that this is the voice of our
Creator God Almighty who created us for
his glory and when they heard the voice
of the Creator they immediately bowed to
his command and seized at his order and
did not resist or fight him what's
ironic is human beings who have int
intelligence still did not know who this
one was in their midst and they were
afraid beautiful you caught it the human
beings who are created an image of God
and have rationality and an intellect
still could not discern this is God In
the Flesh and it freaked them out who is
this man what manner of man is this that
does things that the Old Testament tells
us only God can do and yet the wind and
the waves knew the voice of their
creator when Jesus spoke they recognize
that's our creator he created us he owns
us he sustains us we better listen it's
beautiful
you see and that's what Jesus is saying
he's saying creation with the exception
of humans recognize who I am even demons
here's what's ironic every created thing
animate inanimate with the exception of
humans who have been given Choice
recognize Jesus when he shows up this is
God Almighty the Eternal son it's only
human beings human beings who either
refuse to acknowledge or see who he is
right or don't have that knowledge even
demons know that Jesus is God even
demons because they can't deny who he is
they try to get you to deny it see Satan
and demons they know Jesus is God and
your only hope of Salvation they don't
want you to know it so they will deceive
you into not recognizing who Jesus is or
rejecting who Jesus is but they
themselves know better they know this is
God and he's going to judge us let me
prove that to you are you ready yes go
to Mark 3 read 11 to 12
you're asking superb questions brother
and you're benefiting everyone oh yeah
this is this is wonderful thank you Mark
31-2 11 uh 11 and 12 right Y and unclean
spirits when they saw him fell down
before him and cried saying Thou Art the
Son of God and he straightly charged
them that they should not make him known
isn't it amazing unclean spirits knew
immediately immediately recognized this
is the Son of God In the Flesh whereas
the human being still didn't know who he
was right right right right go to Mark 1
23-
24 and you see their reaction right
these evil spirits these demons they're
trembling with fear and whr and tread
when they see him right right yeah
definitely I'm G show you why that's
important go to Mark 1 23-
24 and there was in their synagogue a
man with an unclean spirit and he cried
out saying let us alone what we to do
with thee thou Jesus of Nazareth Art
Thou come to destroy us I Know Thee who
Thou Art the Holy One of god notice the
reaction they're shouting with fear and
horror and Dread shouting shrieking and
they're begging him please leave us
unone and they know he has the power to
torment and torture them and they know
that he's the Holy One Of
God you see that Absol absolutely but
now few more examples because I'm going
to show you why I'm taking the long
route because you're going to see how
this shows that Jesus is God In the
Flesh though he's not the father or the
Holy Spirit he's a Divine Son of God go
to mark five and read verses 1 to 7 Mark
5 verses 1
to7 EP K you already anticipated where
I'm going with where I'm going
next Mark 5 verses 1
to7 and they came over unto the other
side of the sea into the country of the
gines hope that pronounced that
right and when he was come out of the
ship immediately there met him out of
the tombs a man with an unclean Spirit
who had his dwelling among the tombs and
no man could bind him no not with chains
so no power in all the Earth no human
power no chains could bind him he was
too powerful for all humans and all
chains and all all uh shackles right
exactly okay understand why this is
important Mark wants you to see no human
being could constrain him no shackle no
chain could strain him everyone was
utterly helpless and Powerless against
these demons keep that in mind keep
going because that he had been often
bound with feathers and chains and the
chains had been plucked asunder by him
and the feathers broken in pieces
neither could any man tame him see
nobody no he would break him like butter
and no power no human being could
constrain him he was too much but now
this is what Mark wants you to see he
wants you to see here are demons that no
human power no chain no shackle could
bind everything and everyone was
helpless and hopeless against them
powerless but now notice how powerful
Jesus is now this is what you're
supposed to see how powerful Jesus is
keep
going and always night and day he was in
the mountains and in the tombs crying
and cutting himself with stones but when
he saw Jesus AAR off he ran and
worshiped him God to read for me verse
six again uh but when he saw Jesus AAR
off he ran and worshiped him he
worshiped Jesus right so even the demons
knew that Jesus must be worshiped and
here are his enemies who are
begrudgingly worshiping him right that
fulfills every KNE even demonic knees
must bow to him so then read all the way
to
seven and cried with a loud voice and
said what have I to do with thee Jesus
thou son of the most high God okay go
finish it I'm sorry I didn't mean to
oh that's right I adure Thee by God that
thou torment me not okay catch the
demons know Jesus is Worthy of worship
and they must worship him no realize
that the demons also are definely afraid
of him shrieking with fear they are
horrified at his presence because they
know he's so powerful he can torment
them but here's where you were supposed
to see the irony and how amazing this is
without lifting a finger without saying
a word they're already utterly help less
and hopeless against him even though no
human being was able to contain them or
no human being was able to Shackle them
with chains or shackles because they
were too powerful for mere humans and
too powerful for chains and shackles and
yet with Jesus they're utterly helpless
and hopeless and Powerless and stricken
with fear and Horror in his
presence amen so how can Jesus be a mere
man he's not I love the question at the
end of Mark 4 they say what manner of
man is such telling question you so
notice that Mark just told you these
demons that inhabited these men no human
being could resist them no human being
could restrain them chains and shackles
they cut through like butter but when
they saw Jesus they fall in horror and
Dread and Terror at his feet worship Him
and know that he has the power to
torment torture them and they can't do
anything against them utterly powerless
against
him amen so how powerful is this Jesus
so you got that right yeah yeah okay but
I got a couple more for you now go to
Matthew 8 same story about the same
event Matthew 8
28-29 and when he was come to the other
side into the country of the gines there
met him two possessed with Devils coming
out of the tombs exceeding Fierce so
that no man might pass by that way and
behold they cried out saying what have
we to do with thee Jesus thou Son of God
Art Thou come hither to torment us
before the time wait how did they know
Jesus is the one appointed to destroy
them at the appointed time did you catch
their response have you come before the
appointed time to torment us we know
there's a day set for us we know you're
the one who's going to judge us and
torment us but the time hasn't come why
are you here before that time
exactly so how did they know notice how
much they know about Jesus guys pay
attention because I got one final
example they know that Jesus is the son
of God they know he's the Holy One Of
God they know that they must worship him
they know they're utterly powerless and
helpless and hopeless against him they
know he's so powerful he can torment
them at ease without even lifting a
finger and they know there's an appoint
of time where he will torment them and
torture them they know all this about
Jesus and yet they're seeing Jesus for
the first time on Earth this is the
first time on Earth that they're
encountering Jesus but they know all
this about him already final one Luke
8:31 Luke
8:31 you see how much they know about
Jesus and yet this as far as the gospel
counts are concerned this is their first
Earthly meeting the first time they're
seeing Jesus on
Earth and in in Revelation will these be
among those like under the Earth who are
well read Luke 8:3 that's why I'm having
you read Luke 8:31 okay
okay uh Luke
8:31 and they besought him that he would
not command them to go out into the deep
the Deep the word is Abyss that's in
Revelation 9 what you're referring to
they telling Jesus do not send us to the
abyss the Deep the bottomless pit that's
the same word for bottomless pit so yes
in Revelation 9 when you see the king of
the bottomless pit the Greek word is
Abyss the same word he opens up the
abyss and the demons come out for five
months to torture people these demons
are saying don't send us there to that
Abyss to that bottomless pit to the Deep
it's the same word in Greek used in
Revelation 9 where Satan himself will be
bound in Revelation 20 veres 1 and3 it
says Satan will be bound in that deep
and that Abyss in the bottomless pit for
a thousand
years and who's going to send them there
and bind them there Jesus right right
okay now let's sum it up and if you have
more questions we'll take it I want
everyone get it this is the first
Earthly encounter between Jesus and
these evil spirits this is the first
time they're seeing him on Earth but
notice how much they know about Jesus
they know he's the son of God the Holy
One Of God they know they're utterly
powerless against him hopeless against
him helpless against them they shriek
with horror and Terror and Dread in his
presence they beg him do not torture do
not torment us they worship Him and they
know he has the power to send them to
the abyss and there's an appointed time
where he will torture them and damn them
in hell they know all this about Jesus
but they're seeing him for the first
time and these are demons that no human
being was able to constrain and no
chains or shackle could bind who is this
Jesus that is so powerful that he does
what no human being can do against them
which no shackles or chains can do he's
the all powerful Son of God and notice
the way they react to Jesus is exactly
what James 21:19 says James
2:19 so what it
says would you like me to read 219
yep thou believest that there is one God
thou doest well the Devils also believe
and tremble wait so the Devils know
there's one God
right and what are their reaction
trembled and what are their reaction
before Jesus
uh tremblings so this confirms what I
said in creation even evil spirits
Angelic beings inanimate objects animate
animals sea creatures they all know
Jesus is their Creator God Almighty the
son of the Father the companion of the
spirit it's only human beings among
humans you have people refusing to
acknowledge that or ignorant of that
reality definitely and that was Jesus's
Point even the Stones would praise me
because the stones though inanimate know
I created them and I sustain them just
like the wind and the waves when they
heard my voice they know this is the
voice our Creator God who sustains us we
better
obey right that's the answer amen amen
you have another question brother